A chapter
is a subtopic or a sub of that
particular topic. this book that
we're starting here which is book number
12 in the order of the books of real
said is not a collection of 19 books
is a con a collection of 96 books right
each book has chapters and there may be
subchapters in between so
from
is not very long and we already read it.
We already did this book.
We just finished it. As a matter of
fact, we just finished it two days ago.
So why in the world are we doing it
again?
Because that is the nature of knowledge.
We have to continue to repeat
until we learn. And that's really one of
the big differences between knowledge
and entertainment,
right? You want to be entertained.
Entertainment comes with novelty. It has
to be new, fresh, something that you
have not heard or seen before. It's got
to catch you off guard. The mystique of
it and the novelty of it is what makes
you entertained. That's not what
knowledge is for. Not at all. Knowledge
warrants repetition.
One of
our scholars, he recently passed
away.
He said,
[Silence]
fashion.
He said,
"A teacher who
is not able to be repetitive, a teacher
who's not able to teach the same thing
over and over and over until the
students absorb it and embibe it. A
teacher who becomes wary of repetition
is a failure at teaching.
And a student who is wary of repetition
is a failure as a student.
That's what knowledge is. It has to be
repeated until it's understood.
Now, here's a really interesting
question.
Knowledge, what is knowledge? I mean,
knowledge has a meaning in the Quran and
Sunnet. Has a meaning in our terminology
as people. When we speak we say this
this is knowledge or this person has
knowledge. What is knowledge?
[Silence]
forman.
Sai wasallam. Then
[Silence]
on a sher.
The candle in
[Silence]
Knowledge is
Knowledge is knowing Allah. Knowing the
messenger of Allah, knowing the religion
of Islam with evidence. That's what
knowledge is. Anywhere in the Quran, in
the Sunnah where you see the word
knowledge used, it is only used to mean
that
knowledge of Allah,
knowledge of the messenger of Allah,
knowledge of the religion of Islam
with the evidence
to support it. That's part of knowledge.
This is what knowledge is. So if we know
that's what knowledge is, then the
question
then becomes
who are the people of knowledge?
The people of knowledge, they're
mentioned in the Quran.
[Silence]
And so the people of knowledge are the
people who know Allah, know the
messenger of Allah, know the religion of
Islam with its evidences. That's what
knowledge is. But here's an interesting
point.
Any
information,
any piece of knowledge that is not put
into action
is not considered knowledge for that
person.
Meaning
a person is only considered of the
people of knowledge in the Quran and
Sunnah's terminology
if he implements what he knows. If he
puts what he knows into action, if he
fails to implement
and so
knowledge is only that of it which is
implemented. That's knowledge.
And
we could also say is knowledge just
memorization
let's say for instance someone
memorizes
the Quran
are they a scholar of the Quran? Now
not necessarily right
is knowledge understanding without
memorization.
So let's say a person knows the the
conclusions
but they do not know the actual text. Is
this person have knowledge?
No.
Knowledge is the marriage of
understanding and memorization.
That's what knowledge is.
When we have something that is memorized
and then it is understood, this is
knowledge and implemented.
[Arabic recitation]
in the terminology of the Quran, the
Quran and Sunnah.
This is why we have
for instance, the scholars of evil, the
people of the previous nations, they had
scholars, but they were scholars of
evil. Why? because they did not
implement.
These are considered in the Quran people
of ignorance.
Listen to M.
He says,
[Silence]
for
who are
[Silence]
And so when we have the marriage of
understanding and memorization, this is
what we call knowledge. And in the Quran
only that which is memorized and
understood and put into action is
considered knowledge in the hereafter.
Everything else is not knowledge. It's
you know it's it's facts. It's
information. It's not knowledge.
Knowledge has very specific parameters.
and
knowledge of Allah, of his messenger, of
the religion of Islam, it has to be
implemented.
One final thing, when we hear the word
knowledge in the Quran,
does it mean all and any kind of
knowledge?
No. We already mentioned that knowledge
in the terminology of the Quran is
knowledge of revelation, knowledge of
Allah, his messenger, the religion of
Islam with evidence
and that of it which is implemented
implementation.
Now
any other kind of knowledge
any other kind of knowledge in the Quran
and Sunnah
this is always mentioned with
you know it's always qualified for it to
mean that
[Silence]
Let's say for instance based on what we
just heard,
I'm able to sit here and say
the following issue has been differed
upon amongst the scholars. said the
following and Ahmed said the following.
Abu Hanifh said the following and Malik
said the following. Thus far is any of
that knowledge in what we've just
mentioned
and we have hesitancy now we're
hesitating.
The answer is no. That's not knowledge.
That serves knowledge because it helps
to understand it. But that on its own is
not knowledge.
And this is why we why am I saying this?
Because I want to be able to distinguish
between knowledge and that which serves
knowledge.
So based on that, who knows? How do we
identify a scholar? How do we know who
is a scholar?
Let me ask you a question. Who knows a
pilot? Who knows who who recognizes who
is able to fly a plane?
Other pilots. There is no other way for
that. There's nothing else.
The only person that can tell you if
someone is a pilot is another pilot.
someone is a scholar is another scholar.
That's the only person. No one else can
tell you if someone is a scholar
because it takes knowledge to recognize
[Arabic recitation]